yeah it multiplied by let's say 100 yeah
[Music]
yeah the one I like is uh everyone has
their pods on now right and I think
every pods did one thing like Apple does
really well is nobody wanted to walk
around with the Bluetooth headset right
we think we all agree you didn't look
cool you look attacking like it was a
known douchebag thing yeah yeah it was
like having the cellphone on your belt
yeah perfect and so I was like great
people have a pause now and so what else
can you build with this again Apple's
unlocking capabilities and hardware so
what software can you build and so
there's two ideas ones of minds when
somebody else's but I'll take it as my
great yeah exactly
whoever says it it's theirs yeah by the
way Apple or air pods what how much 10
million units X amount of time so what's
that 10 bit is that 10 billion in sales
yeah just multiply by let's say 100 yeah
yeah it would be a fortune 500 company
yeah I agree it's fantastic and so one
of the things I was thinking about it
was great if I have these on all day can
I just have this on can i connect it to
like my wife or like somebody right and
so whether you do it for work or for a
personal you always have it on there's
no audio flowing but then if I'm like
hey Sean what's up it knows do you have
your ear pods on if it doesn't it tells
me hey he's not there but you could
record a message you'll get it later
right but if you're there you'll just
hear my audio and you still aren't on
yet you're kind of opting again to be
like yo what's up man like it's like how
do you take the phone call away from
like that and you're like I'm not gonna
give this capability to everybody
there's a couple close people in my life
like my wife did I'm gonna be like great
I just want to have this on and this
capability that's there and so it's like
in the office they do this in the TV
show oh yeah Jim and Pam Hammond yeah
this is good cuz it's not it's not on
when you don't want it on so but let's
say I have my earbuds in you have yours
in and I'm walking around I'm at lunch I
have this idea for the podcast I
basically just say yo Sam what we should
do is we should do this and then you
basically receive but you're not sending
back unless you say whatever the keyword
like the how Alexa works right like it's
like Sean or whatever it is and that's
way more lightweight than me
picking on my phone is our native type
or phone call like who wants to do that
right so phone calls feel weird 100%
right now yeah
[Music]